[Music]
action
i don't think so i don't believe oh you
don't think so i don't think so i don't
believe you i'm never gonna listen i
love a dog is that a concha
it's a concha that's a contract what
else is
like a denim hat you brought attention
to it is that food it's nice
it's a bread right oh oh oh oh oh see
it's kind it's a pandora bun and it's
also kind of like melonpan
yes it is anyway
pineapple pan okay so this story here
dog lovers and dog owners will
soon maybe be uh required by law
to marry them no all right
he started laughing with me
oh [ __ ] no no no no no no no no
no okay cut it out no by law what do you
think would be requested
register oh that is the law already
right yeah yeah
okay give us good chip him take them
no obedience training you have to have a
dog license to own a dog pick up the
poop
okay more luckily for that but no no
more look at the pee you you do as a dog
owner but this time it's going to be
required by
law
dude okay so that's like oh you want to
get into
by law you have to walk your dog well
okay how would they attract they can't
make laws that they can't track
i know and expect people to do it that's
the dumbest ones they do yeah what kind
of dog the semi
automatic dogs which dogs are gonna
track okay so this
is why we already banned those long time
ago yeah
so this is taking place in germany
they're saying that pretty soon
it will be required by law to take your
dog
four walks twice a day for at least
one hour in total dude that's a lot of
walking
so 30 minutes each time at least the
german police is doing stakeouts and
they're like
okay we see mr chris kringle over there
he is
not taking his dog out only once today i
know santa claus was german
i thought he was pringles that he was
like klinger
yeah i thought he was uh like nordic
nordic i'm kidding
okay okay okay maybe maybe mr heimlich
mr heimlich mr heimlich mr heimlich is
not doing his duty he's not taking his
docks honestly when they just put like
an apple watch on like this
their little paws oh and they're just
like record steps how cute
i could see that being a problem in
europe because the homes are smaller
but i feel like in like you know like
countryside or like in america
they people have backyards and stuff
that's true it might not be as necessary
as like if you lived in a new york
high-rise where it's
super small maybe it's a lie just to get
the people that are overweight to start
walking
but then it's only with the overweight
people with dogs but then that just
means that okay america statistically
most dog owners would be overweight
for the for that to be the reason that's
why it doesn't make sense be
rusty when i like when you see like
russia they'd be like okay you could buy
a bus ticket or you could do 20 air
squats and this machine will
count you do it it was like russia or
china yeah one of those and it's like
that's dope or like recycling
thing for a ticket yeah that's like
super dope and like
um getting like something like the
the government actually getting involved
in a positive way yeah something that
would like someone would actually do
that's pretty cool yeah because right
now they're saying that these
proposed plans include that the dog
owners will have to take their dogs for
walks twice a day like i said a minimum
of one hour and
yeah lazy ass they will not be allowed
to keep their dogs chained for long
periods of time they will not be allowed
to leave dogs alone the whole day
and breeders will be looking or will be
restricted
to looking after a maximum of three
litters
and puppies will have to spend a minimum
of four hours a day in human company to
ensure that they do get socialized
are you allowed to walk dogs at the same
time because if not you own a dog that's
eight hours of walking
do one after the other oh if it's not
allowed at the same time yeah like
one hour every day total total so like
30 and 30 or less minutes
three twenty minutes two twel uh yeah
good math i don't even walk that much
every day
how am i supposed to even get the dog
out there i'm so anti-government i'll
probably be like oh is that what you
want to do
i'll do 60 times one minute walks
you so damn [ __ ] that is it like
rollover minutes can you walk for like
four hours on a sunday and then just
take
oh that'd be kind of cool do you think
that's how your dog is gonna take it
i don't know you're like dude we went to
the beach it's not like a cat owner all
day yesterday
that was like at least six hours i'm
covered for the week
yeah i wonder if your dog doesn't want
to walk have you seen that dog that like
they're going to try to drag him out
yeah
like what are you going to they're going
to kill him if he doesn't know some dogs
are just like i'm kind of just chilling
well can you just put like a like
monitor or whatever on your dog and then
like send him into the background and
run a bunch of circles and die
cool that's different they're not
monitoring them oh
you're saying yeah this is an honor
system then
yeah it's pretty much like an honor
system but there's how do you make a law
and honor system
i know right well they're saying that
these regulations are more to be honest
they do crack down
on breeders that's the whole that's the
main objective here
is to crack down on breeders and to make
sure that
that uh pets that are kept in shelters
and stuff they actually get proper
care like getting walked getting human
socialization
and that's mainly what the whole
objective is that's pretty cool
okay so you know how there's breeders
right and we kind of don't want breeders
i guess
right now oh you don't want puppy mills
you don't want like
some breeders are actually really good
because they'll say if you get rid of
breeders then who's how the dog's gonna
be born yeah it's more for puppy mills
like the ones that are just like
turning them up yeah and making profits
yeah like some of them like i was
looking at this one they're called um
king shepherds where they take german
shepherds and they mix them with a
pyrenees something and there's something
else and then they're like these really
big like
almost alaskan malamute german shepherds
wow and i was looking at the way that
they breed their dogs it's really cool
like they have a you know like german
shepherds they have hip issues
so uh only puppies that pass
um this certain like hip
numeric or whatever ratio do they get to
keep continue to have
babies so pretty much they breed not
just for
looks but for health too so they have
strong genetics yeah so the breed is
breeding is supposed to happen right
because from what i've heard is that
like irresponsible breeders they end up
creating a weaker breed
yeah no they're making the breed
stronger what's that one that everyone
likes that
pugs that have the breeding problem or
the frenchies french bulldogs yeah
and they like live super short lives you
can't take them on planes one of the
examples that i've heard that breeding
is bad
yeah that sucks but yeah they're saying
that
for in germany that these new
regulations have been drawn up and it
could become law
early next year and it will be up to
german states to enforce it
so we'll see what happens but i just
thought it was really interesting like
imagine we had something like that
something similar in
in the states where it's like by law you
must be walking your dog it would not
fly here yeah
it would not fly yeah
that's funny i'll walk my dog but i
won't wear a mask
they're all march but not the dogs
that's hilarious maybe they'll ride
segways they'll be like i'll take them
out
but i'm not gonna walk put them in a
wagon yeah yeah
so you can't walk yourself you will roll
everywhere
it's a pain in the ass to be a
politician here huh
it's like a group of people that [ __ ]
hate following rules
they should do like a speed dating of
presidents and then they
like for one month all the presidents
switch real quick
and then see like and everyone can rate
that yeah america kind of sucks
oh these are leaders we should have like
whoever is the president the vice
president has to be uh through
uh like republican and democrat and then
that way
so it's like things pass in how families
work with like a mom and a dad they're
usually different roles
the problem with that do you think
co-presidenting maybe but the problem
with that from at least from
a previous perspective it has the most
incentive for the vice president to get
the president assassinated
oh yeah because now he which is why it
can't just be like vice president
it's got to be like romeo juliet it's
got to be like star-crossed
lovers from two different sides they
have to bring in the kingdom you know
what i mean
but then of course we have to sacrifice
them both in some sort of tragic death
in order for us to truly come together
yeah what are we going to do who who
should be the people in the lineup
i don't know i don't have any ideas
imagine it was like that though and then
back when we had the
hillary and donald trump and then
they've got co-presidency
what would that look like i want it from
other countries like a [ __ ] wheel of
fortune with all the leaders
imagine one month we get kim jong-un as
our president thing will change in one
month
kim jong-un for one month here he might
go one month yeah we might go oh [ __ ] we
actually had a lot of really good
presents
that's true if we all had one month of
kim jong-un
i think after he leaves we will be like
oh my god i love being american so much
yeah every country that gets him next
we're like
sweden's president the female right
she's like killing her out there is she
i don't even know who sweden's president
is sweden
i think so that's not good if she's
killing nah
they're killing it are you sure you're
not talking about merkel sister
of sweden oh yeah you're talking about
marco
miss marker is it she's german yeah
that'd be tight
is she good i thought she was not good
the emperors
of europe she rescued europe out of so
many things maybe we need her then
we'll do speed dating of presidents
angela merkel yeah
she's a chancellor of german germany
there is a germany president well who's
who's sweden
oh it was someone else it's not a female
there's a female that's i know i need
to be more bob raymond that doesn't
sound like a female's name oh
the owner of ikea
somehow they make their mazes make me
buy stuff and
there's one way in one way out dude that
place is a worm
you just got to get to the swedish you
can't browse yeah it doesn't matter
where you go as long as you land over it
their food is
really good so good price points price
point is
how i know you give me feed it's like
and they're dessert too oh the desserts
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] sauce it's so
good is that hazelnut
you're new to this channel listen if you
are new to this channel thank you for
coming
thank you so much for coming but that's
something you need to know we love
ikea we always talk about ikea's food
that's true
constantly the lingenberry sauce
it's always still serving food right now
i don't know huh
have you guys been like here recently no
we drove there and we've opened it back
they're open but since they're
practicing social distancing so you know
before it's like everyone just kind of
walks around
now you drive through the whole thing
well no you have to like it's it's like
a couple people at a time so if there's
just even 10 people that are gonna go to
ikea
it takes like two hours to go through it
were you curious just to go there just
to see if it was open because you said
you drove there and drove
no we're we're getting some shopping
okay get something meatballs
we drive there and you see it wrapped
all the way outside and i don't know
because like that
their stuff is so cheap i love it though
but how
because their lines are crazy long and
how much people are buying and
everything
and then it's like how much their profit
is
that they're able to offer like delivery
and uh building for like 10 cents extra
10 cents it's [ __ ] cheap oh it's so
like that's why i like now whenever i
get anything i'm not going to just
haven't built it yeah
and they're good at it too they're quick
yeah i'll build it for you
i like building a kiss please it's the
most painful my most favorite thing my
most favorite pastime
your mom that's her asmr yes it is i am
a very interesting person apparently she
built all of my stuff i was like thank
you
i don't want to touch it is it just ikea
it's got to be like swedish branded
no just furniture that you build i
[ __ ] what about like deconstructing
and like packing up my apartment if i
wanted to move
maybe twenty dollars maybe and do you
like building with instructions or with
that
it has to have instructions oh it's i
think it should be like a
uh olympic games like building ikea
furniture
without um instruction instructions
they'll just memorize it right
but that's the thing you have to
memorize like thousands of different
things because they have everything
yeah oh you don't know what thing is
going to come out yeah oh how fun
oh my god i should have been a jk party
game i think that would have been a fun
one that would be really good
but like you have to give us time to
prepare though so you have to give us
all the
the study material yeah study material
no no
you just get both you guys get like the
same thing you don't know what it is and
then it's you have to unbecause even
oh my god that's so fun can we do that
that'd be fun
i want to do it what that episode is
like six hours long just frustrated
that was so much fun oh that sounds so
funny because i [ __ ] love puzzles and
[ __ ] so that would
just do like a
[Laughter]
it's the motion of like just getting it
in you know
yeah good
[Music]
you